today President Biden did eventually
make it to Chicago and gave a speech on
what he is now calling bidenomics
meaning our economy is failing and he
claimed the economy is doing great but
the numbers they tell a different story
Biden falsely claimed to have created
over 13 million new jobs the real number
is less than 4 million he bragged about
10 million new businesses but left out
the fact that there's 10 million open
jobs that employers can't fill and what
about wages when you account for
inflation oh they're up a mere 0.2
percent from last year and as the FED
continue to raise rates to combat
Biden's inflation well the cost of
everything for mortgages car loans
credit cards has spiked no wonder many
Americans allow living almost 60 percent
paycheck to paycheck and the average
American now owes over 54 000 how do you
pay that back here with uh is the host
of making money on Fox Business Charles
Payne
five nomics yeah what part of the
economy is working because I I can list
the part that's not working I tell you
what's really revving up uh the Repo Man
they can't they can't hire enough they
really can't they cannot hire enough
that's the fastest growing industry in
this country you know here's the thing
president buying a Corvette I've been
waiting I heard about that Z06 and when
I get it it better not get repoed yeah
no I got a feeling you'll be okay just a
gut feeling a gut feeling you know the
old political term a chicken in every
pot yeah so someone in Biden
Administration said how about we give
like 40 million chickens to every pot
like you know like the 1.9 trillion
dollars if we pump that into the economy
we could just live off of that forever
but you know what there's a funny thing
about free money it's not free and
Americans have learned that the hard way
so now we've been dealing with this
massive inflation the highest inflation
in a generation over 40 years you've had
you've people in this country half the
people in this country never even knew
anything about that it's 60 of the
population plus are living paycheck to
paychecks right some people cashing in
their pensions great penalties some
people people putting Bare Necessities
on credit cards I've lived paycheck to
paycheck it sucks and then fifty four
thousand dollars in debt right and then
they're going to ask those people to pay
off the student loans of people that
voluntarily borrow the money right yeah
I mean tell the folks who uh who have
the highest unemployment make the least
amount of money to pay people who have
the lowest unemployment they make all
the money uh to pay their bills it's
nuts by the way it's not it's not their
sneakers
that would chip away at it if you guys
see the market up like 200 points that
means we've got a deal 1100 sneakers
they're beautiful but wow well you when
you pay that much for them though you
take care of them yeah
Bible I'm jealous well you know what
else
you've done with this though is they've
changed the you know pull yourself up by
the bootstraps that's a very important
key to why we're so successful so when
you tell people don't pay your rent for
a couple years when you tell people
don't pay your student loans for a
couple years when you tell people don't
work because I'll pay you twice as much
to stay at home then to go to work you
start to erode the foundation of what
made America great let me tell you
what's that getting up I can't imagine
for a working age American getting up
every day and not having something to do
you know what we're all designed to
serve other people in some capacity and
not to find your purpose is is to me one
of the biggest shames of of big
government you know I agree one thousand
percent I believe God has given us all
an innate ability to excel at something
all right and the life and Journey's
life that we can go after that it's a
blessing amen appreciate it you too man
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else